hi guys I'm Greg I'm Lauren there you go
man so Lauren has worked with a talented
actress youtuber called Syd Wilder yes I
recently was in it Syd Wilder sketch
uber therapy I'm a goober driver in this
one that's really funny I like that idea
yeah yeah you'll see how it works yeah
the fun shoot shot late at night said
while they only wanted me because of my
looks
uh-huh matter than my talent did she
sexually harass you he sexually harass
me come on look at me
and I look at Syd Wilder that message
which is all up on this hotness it's
ridiculous how like come on girl I'm Way
out of your league not she's beautiful
and talented you got some similar work
ethics yeah he's up [ __ ] like always
we're getting Jamie always our a-game
yeah yeah very similar and I did see
didn't touch my body challenge with her
right yeah I did ten videos period are
you did yeah I think that one she's just
as quirky in real life as she is on on
camera is accordi you and me for the
first time let's see this is the first
time I can see this oh I haven't yet I
haven't seen this sketch now I'm going
to judge myself I'm excited let's watch
it you know I want to show Jon Jon
squeeze in yes all right and everyone
squeeze in we're all gonna watch my uber
therapy's catch John help me rehearse my
lines oh good did nice
I do raise it em until it was perfect
but this is really more about Sid okay
[Music]
[Music]
is it a correct address yeah we should I
miss house okay what is it located icon
means line up
I am heating a bourbon right here and
I'm thinking about how much better real
me dancing yo I can't believe it over
with okay
that are we going yeah I'm gonna problem
ID I look at me I usually saw a feeling
to me : look to you look here we've been
here for over an hour
why can you drink okay but the meter is
still running she's so great he's
calling me a Tory but like you know
where it's gonna make it right
you nearly go you know no problem
listen I have to go pick up a regular
customer now nobody was it oh you are
amazing your reactions
I just died I know a thing or two about
reacting never gonna leave you oh my god
so what was that accident you're doing a
shot in Russia Dracula really really
great house looking in and out of it no
I thought that was awesome I thought
that was really good I listened to like
two videos on how to do
Russian accent today yeah ruching like
they say what is it John the the double
use are like what that's where I thought
my dragon look what we yeah cuz it's not
it was not Mademoiselle be using V sound
the same yeah I think they blur in the
middle of where your teeth and your lips
me I don't I guess it's a straight up
but yeah [ __ ] whatever it's a H's like
how like I think it's behind the scenes
interview of the sketch I think it has
like your lips probably touch your top
teeth but they don't like press the way
you gotta go to bite your look yeah you
should give me that advice before I film
the [ __ ] sketch i'm not how to break
it down give me this advice i would get
and what about like 10 accent not my
tempo your reactions are really funny
thank you how you like the faces you
were doing like you just look younger
man you look like you really didn't want
to be I've got this crazy girl out of my
car now thank you yeah I did a lot of
character building and a lot of history
and prior moments I had this whole dream
Oh buddy have a limo business one day
yeah America from Russia you got a whole
background ready for this guy
you look like you're thinking about a
lot of stuff and those inserts of you
like usually you look like you're please
welcome thank you
I loved it thank you read a lot improv
you know the whole thing was a makeup
going on the floor at the end it was all
improvised I love this that originally
and I was like you know I'm feeling it
I'm feeling it country is an inward
subscribe to Sid Wilders channel you go
watch this video give it some views
click in the original video say that for
more video third a subscriber the Rio
reject Lauren Francesca Iowa my Lauren
on YouTube and like everything else if
not she's Lauren Francesca all links in
the description books June is the
reasons to get you on how to be
speakable me or who you're gonna get
you'll recover jaws reads Jets under mr.
Kevin doesn't mean a measure of blue my
Maria reject goodbye